one of the problems of this of course is
in recent years we've been talking about
etiquette of sex and particularly sex
between sexes through the prism of
Hollywood and celebrity and it's just
should be clear to us by now this isn't
the best prism to see these things
through it's I don't know it's like
trying to work out drinking etiquette
from geordie football team or a Geordie
or like it's or a Scotsman yeah I can
say that I'm in Newcastle summer that's
a Geordie sir right so but you know this
has become a real problem our societies
because apart for anything else I think
young men young heterosexual men are
being told things that are not possible
to do and sustained and you know and I I
spoke recently to a friend whose son had
just just left school I said I hadn't
seen the sample while friends with older
than me and I said oh how's the boy and
he said could I say what do you think
about girls he said there was nothing to
do with them and I said what I know and
I said but what what well he's not gay
is he so no no no it's okay
she's just they're more trouble than
they're worth so it's just he thinks her
a nightmare and I've come across that
quite a lot actually because it is it is
being made harder than it needs to be
made I think the the relations between
the sexes has definitely got a lot less
exciting they did you remember flirting
do you remember one other thing yeah
same as its it flirting's the same as
tom boys and emos remember emos where
they've gone anywhere emos I'm seeing an
emo in like I don't miss them I have to
say you get fair enough for too much eye
shadow but anyway you got me like you do
all these things like they feel like
[ __ ] nostalgia now I know flirting is
an amazing because there's a load of
thing we just had this by the way in the
UK today about the ridiculous claims
that our Prime Minister once put his
hand on a woman's leg 20 years ago this
is a headline this is the headline on
the day we're speaking you know number
one news item and all that as much else
to talk about in the world
is there but you know there's this
strange thing where I mean this the
point is this is so complicated because
again we keep having this stuff out on
that sort of level the former Defence
Minister Michael Fallon had to resign I
like being the defense mister is a
really serious job it's not like
agriculture transport you know but I
thought transport relations Oh am I
gonna get the farm but it's not like
transport so your Defence Minister
you've got part of the control of the
nuclear capability you could destroy
Paris if you wanted you have it's a
serious job is embroil he's embroiled in
touching a woman's leg or something and
and and and somebody as it happens you
are who i know a journalist in the UK
had told the story some time before this
he touched her knee or something and
she'd said again not all women can do
this or want to do this it's not to say
this is always good but this this woman
you know said if you keep your hand on
my knee I'll sock you in the bloody face
or something and he took his hand off
pretty fast that was it that was it and
then you know 15 or 20 years later the
story came out again he had to resign I
mean this is so in a way it's a sort of
a British sex scandal there's no sex
it's like Liberal Democrat sex scandal
they're always that like that there's
always like a fat man asked a woman for
a coffee and she said no and that was it
and even if any asked to resign and that
actually happened that actually happened
anyhow the point is is that these are
people look at this and they think what
exactly are the rules and the answer is
we're making them up as we go along
which is not uncommon but we're making
up rules that are completely
contradictory and I give the example in
the book of like what are you to make
growing up of the fact that you are
simultaneously told that women must
always be believed and the most popular
book for women in recent years the Fifty
Shades stories where women have rape
fantasies but growing up is hard
anywhere
and these levels of not being able to
discuss things mean that people just see
these totally contradictory messages in
the culture and I don't blame them for
being utterly Vermeer's
[Music]
you